hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast advances in cellular
automation presented by Mike OLT PhD we
are excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labret skaam the leading social media
site for science professionals and
sponsored by beckman coulter life
sciences recommend culture life sciences
develops manufactures and markets
products that simplify automate and
innovate complex biomedical testing more
than 275,000 beckman coulter systems
operate in both diagnostics and life
sciences laboratories on seven
continents for over 75 years our
products have been making a difference
in people's lives by improving the
productivity of medical professionals
and scientists supplying critical
information for improving patient health
and delivering trusted solutions for
research and discovery to learn more
about beckman coulter life sciences
please visit www IM jus do arc of lab
roots and i'll be your moderator for
today's event before we begin I would
like to remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on the screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice you'll be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge this window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
and finally if you have trouble skiing
or sharing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or you can
use the Q&A button to let us know that
you're having a problem thank you now
I'd like to introduce dr. Kowalski Mike
Kowalski is a staff application
scientist and sample preparation and
applied markets group of beckman coulter
life Francis he received his PhD in
microbiology and molecular genetics from
Harvard University prior to joining
Beckman dr.
all ski was a postdoctoral fellow at the
novartis institutes for biomedical
research where he used automation she
screamed from novel regulators stem cell
pluripotency and differentiation since
joining Beckman mike has developed
automated applications in the areas of
cell culture cellular analysis and mass
spectrometry please join me in welcoming
dr. Kowalski I will now turn the
presentation over to him all right thank
you Judy for the introduction and thank
you everyone for attending today as you
mentioned I'll be talking about some of
the work we've done to automate cellular
applications using our new biomech I
series before we begin we do have a few
disclosures to a to show and we'll now
move on to the actual talk itself so
this webinar is part of the series that
have been presented with the earlier
talks having described how the biomech I
series can provide simplicity efficiency
adaptability and reliability for those
who are unable to attend the earlier
talks I'll just give a brief overview of
the biomech I series instrument but
mostly we'll focus on how this
simplicity efficiency adaptability and
reliability can be applied to a variety
of cellular workflows including eliza's
flow cytometry sample prep transfection
optimization and basic cell culture so
for the brief introduction the new i
series come in two different formats the
i-5 shown on the left has a single pod
which can either have a multi-channel
head such as a 96 or a 384 channel head
or it can have a span 8 pipettors which
the each of the probes can spread out
allowing you to access multiple tubes at
once shown on the right is the biomech
i7 this can have up to two heads so we
can have either a single multi-channel
or single span 8 head or it can have
dual multi channels or one of each a
span eight and a multi-channel it
obviously has a larger footprint than
the ipod shown on the left some of the
new features that are shown on I series
include a status light shown at the top
of the enclosure to the right this light
can basically indicate what is happening
while on the system whether it's
currently running whether it needs to
have an interaction or whether it's in
standby mode and there's also a new deck
LED light which helps illuminate the
deck for configure a ting for kicks
configuring the deck as well as just
keeping an eye on what's happening
however this light can be turned off if
you're working with light-sensitive
reagents there's also an optional
enclosure shown to the right and this is
very useful for cell culture
applications because it can be
configured with HEPA filtered fans to
ensure a sterile working environment it
also can enable direct integrations also
shown to the right and we'll cover a
number of these throughout the talk
whether it be plate readers incubators
flow cytometers etc and both of the
instruments have a configurable high
density deck shown on the lower left the
biomech I five deck has up to 25
microtiter plate physicians and the i7
has up to 45 microtiter plate positions
and these can be configured in different
ways with different positions for
heating and cooling for trash or washes
etc and each of the systems features a
high axis rotating gripper this allows
complete coverage of the deck so that
all positions can be accessed and
because of the high access you can also
pick up a microtiter plate next to a
taller piece of lab where such as a tip
box there's one for head so if you have
two heads on the system you would have
two grippers when it comes to a liquid
handlers obviously liquid handling is
still tacky so we have made some
improvements to the multi-channel head
one of the main features is that there's
now a 1200 microliter capacity head this
enables you to transfer a 1 mil per tip
and while also having a 20-percent
additional blah to ensure all the liquid
is removed from the tips and the head
now also features selective tip
pipetting so enabling you to pick up a
single column a single row or a single
tip or any combination of tips as needed
this obviously gives a lot more
flexibility than being forced to always
use 96 or 384 tips at once on the span
aid side we now have per probe
calibration so obviously we know there
may be some slight inherent differences
between the pumps and so this is really
enables you to dial in the accuracy at
the low end if needed so obviously
having the ability to calibrate each
probe can really provide some of that
addition
precision and also from a simplicity
standpoint we now have a volume
splitting feature that all you have to
do is check a checkbox and if you asked
you transfer a volume that is more than
the tip capacity or the head capacity
the biomech will do the calculations and
split it into the number of transfers
needed to reach that volume we also have
a deck observation system so this
basically entails to wide-angle cameras
one on each of the front corners of the
system this it can enable remote
monitoring obviously for longer
workloads you may not necessarily want
to stay by the instrument so this allows
you to monitor what's happening on the
instrument from your desktop or your
laptop computer and another feature is
that it will record 30 seconds on both
before and after any error that occurred
so obviously a good way to troubleshoot
if something has gone wrong we also
offer the pro service remote management
system and just going to actually allow
our tech support folks to access some of
the error logs or possibly look at some
of those minute long videos to try and
get an idea of what if any maintenance
is needed for the system and this should
enable them to bring the parts they
would need to help save an additional
trip and finally the system is windows
10 compatible which is great for moving
forward as more and more instruments
will be running on Windows 10 so moving
now into the cellular applications we'll
start out with an Eliza method so I
think most people are familiar with
Eliza's it's obviously pretty ubiquitous
it is a fairly labor-intensive process
though and shown on the lower left-hand
side is just the workflow that we use
for our proof of principle work this was
an il-22 Eliza kit that was just
commercially available and the steps
include doing a serial dilution using
the automation then adding a dive events
and the samples and standards to the
plate shaking it for two hours doing
four washes adding a conjugate to the
plate and then shaking for another two
hours followed by additional washes and
then a 30 minute incubation with the
substrate adding a stop solution and
then reading absorbance so a fairly
straightforward workflow but again one
that is done manually can essentially
take the good portion of the day and
just requires quite a number of liquid
transfers
shown on the lower right-hand side is
the deck of the i5 if you wanted to use
fresh tips for each transfer you can see
very quickly how the deck fills up and
this is one of the advantages of the
high-capacity deck is that we're able to
incorporate all this lab where during
the workflow another one of the
challenges for elijah's is that it's
frequently a very highly variable and
throughput the same workflow could be
used for just a saying eight to twenty
four samples or it could be a much
higher throughput type of application
where you're screening for igg producing
clones where it could be in the hundreds
to thousands of samples so we'll keep
this in mind as we talk about more of
the workflow so for the proof of
principle we use the biomech I five span
8 system kind of shown to the right and
we were able to process a full plate in
six and a half hours and obviously using
the span 8 system this would be more of
a low to medium throughput probably one
to two plates a day of that six and a
half hour workflow four and a half hours
were just straight incubations and
obviously when we do a lysis manually
typically this involves adding wash
buffer and then inverting the plate over
some waste and shaking it out and blot
again against a pad this is not
something that's very automation
friendly so to ensure that we have
removed all the liquid from the plates
we use our optimized by petting
techniques to aspirate around the
circumference of the well sort of at the
north south east and west quadrants and
this ensured that we were able to remove
all the liquid from the flat bottom
wells we were able to achieve excellent
standard curves as shown by the
precision of our the reproducibility of
our triplicate values and our standard
curve shown on the lower left hand side
where all the feebies of our replicates
were under five percent and we also had
excellent linearity as indicated by the
r-squared value of point nine nine one
for our standard curve indicating our
automated serial dilution was highly
effective so this is a fairly
straightforward application but
obviously if you want to do those types
of higher throughput applications that i
mentioned earlier such as clone
screening there are a number of
considerations when moving to that
higher throughput the first is that
you'll likely need to move to a
multi-channel system the nice thing with
having the Selective tip feature is that
even if you're
saying 24 or the examples this still can
be done using the multi-channel head
using the Selective tip feature another
consideration is deck space as I showed
before this could require a lot of tips
a lot of buffers or reservoirs that's
for a single place so if you have
additional place having the higher debt
capacity of an i7 might be valuable or
you might need to integrate some
additional storage positions and we have
lab where feeders that would allow you
to have lots of tips or plates available
for higher throughput another
consideration is dead volume obviously
if you're using a multi-channel
reservoir the deadline for those are
roughly 20 mils which obviously be more
than you would have available for some
of the regions such as antibodies but
wash buffer etc might be very plentiful
and so you would need to consider the
balance between speed and throughput
versus just how much r eh and you have
available and again using the Selective
tip feature you could go ahead and use
that for the antibodies well using all
96 channels for the wash and another
consideration is scheduling obviously if
you're processing multiple place and if
you want to compare those results across
the plates you need to ensure you have
consistent timing this may not
necessarily be so essential for a two
hour incubation but some of those
substrate incubations at the end of the
license may call for only five to ten
minutes possibly as low as two minutes
before you are required to add your stop
solution and for this you obviously want
to put some timing constraints in and
that's one of the nice features of our
sam eex scheduling software shown on the
lower right hand corner is that again
you can allow the software to try and
schedule as the place as efficiently as
possible but for some of those critical
steps you are able to put in constraints
and ensure that each plate is treated
consistently so moving on now to flow
cytometry sample prep there are a number
of challenges to consider when preparing
samples for flow cytometry analysis the
first main consideration is that you
require single-cell suspensions and if
you're working with an adherent cell
line this requires a trypsinization step
now typically cells may often cluster
together during trypsinization and this
is when it's essential to have something
like the
multichannel head where you can do
repeated pipetting up and down to ensure
that those clumps are broken into their
single-cell suspensions that you require
another consideration is sample
throughput and a lot of this will be
determined by your flow cytometers if
your flow cytometer takes single tubes
or a carousel of tubes your throughput
will likely be lower than if your
cytometry connect what can acquire
samples using a play based format
however we do have automated solutions
for both of those types of workflows and
in fact you may be able to process your
samples in place and then do with finals
transfer to tubes if you're psycho meter
requires it another consideration is
that most of the work clothes for flow
cytometry such as antibody staining
workflows require a centrifugation step
to pellet the cells and allowing you to
perform reagent exchanges such as
antibody washes etc another
consideration is that most of the
reagents are fluorescent and so this
typically means they are light sensitive
so you need to consider how long you're
able to leave your reagents on the deck
of your instrument and we'll talk about
each of these requirements as we go
forward for our proof of principle
experiments we basically wanted to
perform a drug discovery screen and so
for this we use three inducers of a
pitocin screen two different cancer cell
lines to look at their effectiveness
both using dilution curves so looking at
different concentrations of the drugs
and also looking at their effects over
multiple time points we use one
adherence in one suspension cell line
the hct116 colon carcinoma cells were
adherent and that your cat leukemia cell
line was our suspension example as I
mentioned before the HTT 116 cells
required that repeated pipetting using
the multi-channel head during the
trypsinization step to ensure we had
single cells we then stay in the cells
for with markers for apoptosis using a
fluorescent caste-based 37 substrate and
we also added a drak 7 cell impermeable
nuclear die as an indicator of cell
death looking at for a compromise cell
membranes we then acquired our data
using the site of flex flow cytometers
and the system we use has can acquire 15
parameters and 10 colors although there
are now even
versions of this I think that go up to
20 or so colors and the nice thing about
the site of flex is that it can
accommodate either tubes or plates and
obviously we want with the plate loader
for our work today we then did the
analysis using our colusa G software
will now show a brief video that will
illustrate some of the early portion of
the workflow where we focus on the
treatment of the cells this video will
demonstrate our automated flow cytometry
workflow specifically the initial
compound solution and treatment of our
cell culture plate shown here the span
aid system has loaded seven tips is
transferring our drug diluent into a
plate that currently has the highest
concentration of our compounds in the
top row for this demonstration we will
are testing three compounds and so we
will have a final dose response curve of
24 wells each with eight delusions of
three compounds following this transfer
one of the new features of the iseries
is having a universal tip type these
tips can then be shared between both the
span 8 pod and the multi-channel pod
which is very beneficial when only using
partial tip boxes show next is the
selective tip feature of the
multi-channel head enabling us to load
just three tips which will then be used
to do a row wise dilution in a
one-to-one fashion of our three
compounds once the serial dilution is
complete as mentioned we will have 24
total wells eight different
concentrations of three compounds we
then load 24 tips using the Selective
tip feature on the multi-channel head
and these compounds will then be stamped
into the cell plate shown in the
position behind it by doing this
repeated stamping not only are we able
to do dose-response curves we're also
able to establish a time course of
treatment by just processing partial
plates
so now we'll look at some of the data
again this was following this with the
hct116 cells so following the treatment
of the cells we then automated the
trypsinization using the same 24 tips in
the Selective tip fashion and then edit
our staining reagents and did our
analysis so looking here we're looking
at a single time point at 48 hours after
treatment and shown on the x-axis is our
cat space 37 staining and on the y-axis
azhar drag seven staining and we
basically pick just three out of our
eight treatments sort representing a
high medium and low concentration of our
compounds in this particular case we're
looking at 5-fluorouracil treatment and
what you can see is as you decline from
the highest concentration to the lowest
concentration the number of cells found
in the dead and apathetic gates to
decrease indicating our serial dilution
was effective and in fact we can
actually plot some nice dose response
curves with all of the data that we
achieved and what you can see is that
looking at this hct116 cell line at 48
hours we see that stores pouring in camp
at thiessen were far more effective at
killing these cells than 5-fluorouracil
looking at the ic50 concentrations of 63
a molar 317 and molars roughly a
thousandfold more effective than 368
micromolar required to get fifty percent
cell death in this hct116 cell line so
again a nice to illustration of a dose
response but we also wanted to look at
different time courses and shown here is
our jurkat cell line again the
suspension cell lines are no
trypsinization required we simply added
our reagents and dinner analysis and
this was looking at a single
concentration of campus decent treatment
at 78 nano molar and what you can see is
over time the untreated cells shown in
the Bible gate in the lower left
quadrant after 24 hours move into the
apathetic quadrant so they're staying
positive forecast-based 37 but still
very few are staying for drag 7 and then
with an additional 24 and 48 hour
treatment
you see more and more percentages of the
cells moving into that dead quadrant in
the upper right-hand quadrant this can
also be plotted out and what you can see
is a corresponding decrease in the
viable cell count at 24 hours with an
increase in the apathetic Peppa taught
excels qualify as subsequent decrease in
the apoptotic cells with an increase in
the number of dead cells so again a nice
illustration of time-dependent responses
in this particular cell line as shown by
flow cytometry there are some additional
considerations when thinking about flow
cytometry we've already touched on some
of them some of the work flow will be
determined again by the flow cytometers
if you require tubes or plates so it's
nice to have the span ate a pod with
working with tubes again this can be the
entire workflow can be processed in
tubes using the span aid or like I
mentioned before you can actually do the
processing at a plate and do a final
transfer with the span 8 into the tubes
in a very rapid fashion it's certainly
useful to have that multi-channel head
for the resuspension of adherent cells
if that's required but again if folks
are working on blood samples etc that
may be less of a consideration what we
showed today was a relatively simple
example of just an ad and read type of
essay however most of the more typical
workflows would require antibody
staining in this more of a complex
sample prep requiring washes and reagent
exchanges these types of workflows can
definitely be aided by integrations and
shown on the lower right-hand side we
did have an i5 system that we
demonstrated the integration of the site
o flex itself so if you were processing
numbers large numbers of samples the
integration allows the analysis to begin
right at the completion of sample
preparation without any intervention we
also in kind of on the right hand side
of that image you can see a microplate
centrifuge that can be directly
integrated onto the deck and again this
is excellent for the spin down and wash
steps for those antibody type protocols
we also have the option to integrate a
plate washer if this would help assist
things however the multichannel can
essentially do most of the sport flow by
itself with the addition and removal of
washes etc
and there's also the ability to it
integrate incubators either something
small shown as the single plate
incubator next to the site Oh flex in
the image or much larger higher capacity
center of incubators such as this item
at to see and this would be good for say
long long-term staining or again just
similar treatments like we had where you
would treat a comp treats cells with
compounds let them incubate and then
bring the cells back up from the
incubator and do your standing once
again I've already mentioned our Sammy
TX software this software would also be
useful for this type of application for
these higher throughput methods where
again it can process multiple plates in
staggered fashion and once again you can
put in those type of timing constraints
for these steps that are essential one
example would be trypsinization
obviously you want to consistently treat
your plates because if you have longer
trypsinization times this could actually
change the cell surface expression of
some proteins as more of them get cleve
during longer trypsinization treatments
so when i move on to another example
being transfection optimization so when
I think of transfection it seems
relatively simple essentially it's just
combining a lipid with a nucleic acid
and putting it on top of cells however
this does not necessarily it's not
necessarily simple for every cell type
and because of this an optimization
approach can help unfortunately
optimizing transfection conditions is
not so central for this example we chose
to you the design of experiment or a do
we approach where we change the
different lipids we were using we try
different lipid concentrations different
concentrations of nucleic acids and
different cell numbers to see if we
could identify an optimal condition for
a variety of different cell lines the
problem with this Pro char the
difficulty with this approach is that
first off from an automation perspective
you need ways to create these
combinations and again this is a nice
example of how having the Selective tip
feature for the multi-channel head
really enable some of these because you
can do row wise or column wise transfers
as well as any combination you might
need in addition the other problem is
that the conditions increase max
toralei's so it's very quickly as as you
add more and more conditions the number
of samples you need to test grow pretty
dramatically very quickly and will show
an illustration of that as well so the
workflow that so the approach that we
took to automating the transfection
optimization is we started with an empty
plate and then tried six different lipid
conditions really five different
commercial lipids that were available
dartmouth beck one through four and lip
effect amine and one condition that had
no lipids so essentially our
untransfected control we use our span 8
system to transfer these reagents from
tubes into the upper row of the 96-well
plate and i also use of the span age to
just fill in the next 18 wells with
media for serial dilutions shown in the
dark and light purple we also use a
spanning to transfer to different
concentrations of our nucleic acid we
did a SI RNA control and on the next
step we loaded six tips on our
multi-channel selective tip much like
you saw earlier with the three tips for
the flow cytometry example and we did a
serial dilution in a row wise fashion to
get 24 different conditions of lipids
and then stamp those into the lower 24
wells using the same six tips we then
use their span eight at the same time to
essentially stamp out those nucleic
acids into the remaining forty eight
wells on the right-hand side we then
loaded 48 tips on the multi-channel
selective tip and combine those 48 wells
on the left to the 48 wells on the right
resulting in 48 different conditions of
nucleic acid and lipid combinations
following an incubation to allow for
transfection complexes to form we then
stamp those 48 conditions into a
384-well plate and then loaded 96 tips
to transfer to different concentrations
of cells repo resulting in fifteen
thousand or 7500 cells per well the
final result was 96 different conditions
and shown in the plate map below and
that for blue wells indicate the four
replicate conditions for a given
condition such in this case was point 8
microliters of Dharma feck one with a
hundred nana molars of SI r
and 15,000 cells per well so the nice
feature here is we're able to test 96
different conditions in quadruplicate
for optimization in a single plate if we
try to do this manually my best estimate
would be that it would take about 138
manual transfers and instead the
automation was able to achieve this in
under 20 minutes we then tested this
approach on three different cell lines
the hct116 cells I've already mentioned
before and two additional cancer cell
lines an ACH n line which is renal
carcinoma and a tank one pancreatic
carcinoma cell line are we use SI glow
green as our transfection marker this is
a fluorescently labeled SI RNA and 24
hours after transfection we edit our
same direct 7 reagent as a marker for
toxicity and we then performed a media
exchange using the multi-channel head
again to try and reduce the amount of
background we got from the SI glow green
we then did some imaging with the
spectra max I 3x with mini max 300
imaging cytometers shown in the upper
right and this basically enables for X
images to be taken in brightfield and
two fluorescent wavelengths 541
nanometers and 713 nanometers and what
this enabled us to do was to count total
cells and then get an idea of our
transfection efficiency by counting the
number of green cells indicating our SI
glow green had been taken up we also
looked at toxicity so the number of red
nuclei divided by the total number of
cells we looked at whether we had either
inhibited cell growth or whether we had
lost any cells during our media
replacement by comparing our transfected
well to our untransfected wells and the
bright field images and then we also
looked at transfection consistency by
looking at the CVS across our
quadruplicate wells so no need to really
look at the numbers here but i'll
basically summarized the first set of
wells on the left Green is good this is
basically an indication of getting over
thirty percent transfection the next set
of columns red is bad this is basically
any conditions that resulted in toxicity
more than five percent of the
of control Wells the next set Brown is
bad is kind of difficult to see but
again this is where we had less than
eighty percent of our untransfected cell
counts in it well and then on the final
set of columns light green is good this
is where our transfection TVs were below
ten percent so again really the the take
home message here is we sort of
identifies the best conditions by the
bold squares around those wells and the
take home here is that you can
definitely see there are differences
across the three cell lines and will
really identify those in the next slide
so shown here are kind of the resulting
optimal conditions for each of the cell
lines and again what you can quickly see
is that there are differences between
the cell lines all three of them had
different ideal lipids that were used at
different concentrations different
concentrations of Si RNA but through
optimization we were able to achieve
roughly fifty percent transfection
efficiency with all three cell lines
with acceptable levels of toxicity and
with CVS below ten percent some of the
cell lines like Hank one in hct116 were
relatively on a relatively transfection
friendly and that there were a couple
different concentrations that might work
but the ACH n cells were significantly
different and really more troublesome to
transfect and really we did have to find
that optimal condition to to achieve
that type of transfection efficiency
some of the important take-home messages
where that even as a simple change even
just the two fold change in lipid
concentrations you would see very
dramatic effects to fold too low and you
would see very low transfection
efficiency basically nothing to fold too
high and you would see rampant toxicity
depending on your cell line so again
really driving home the need to do this
type of optimization approach in
addition because we were able to work in
384 well format this helped reduce our
reagent usage so again these are not
cheap reagents so obviously the more you
can do in a smaller volume the better
but to try and do this manually this
really adds to it adds challenge to this
because again it's very difficult to
tell which welds you've added reagents
to etc and another nice thing is now
that we have this automated approach
it's very easily adapted to different
either nucleic acids or different
so if you wanted to adapt this to an
overexpression type of essay just change
three agents possibly change your
transfection reagents and add plasmids
instead of SI rnas and it should
essentially work alternatively if you
didn't want to use a fluorescent SI RNA
as a marker instead you had some sort of
phenotypic readout it might just be
requiring changing the the assay
approach at the end so now we'll sort of
conclude with basic cell culture
approaches and again this is something
that not necessarily everyone thinks
about automating because it's something
that was typically done at the bench but
this really is something that can
benefit from automation there's a number
of reasons for that because there are a
number of challenges associated with
cell culture the first is that it's
basically very time consuming and this
can be because it recurs frequently
you're probably passages if you have
multiple cell lines going at the same
time the throughput can become really
burdensome and it's relatively
inflexible it really sells don't really
care if you have an all-day meeting
scheduled if they're confluent they need
to be passed that day in addition
there's high variability in this type of
work for example sometimes you just have
cells that you're waiting to plate later
in the week and so maybe you don't have
that much work but monday may look very
different than thursday or this week may
look very different than next week in
addition we know there are people in the
lab who passage so differently than i do
and so for example if we all sort of
come up with our own approach for
passages and it sort of just depends on
how we were taught or maybe what the
written protocol says but we know
there's inherent variability in the way
people do things and so by turning to
automation this variability can go away
because a lot of the times this
variability will show up in your future
assays and finally it comes down to
scheduling as well when do I need cells
when am I going to plate my experiments
when i'm doing multi day workflows
frequently again some of these cell
culture at these may take days to weeks
what planning ahead do i need to do to
ensure that i'm not here all day on a
weekend and so these are just some of
the considerations that can hopefully be
addressed through automation for the
work we've done this will be done on an
i7 as same as most of the
it has been done previously and it
features a number of integrations which
will show shortly the work we did
involve just culturing to adherence cell
lines cho cells which will show most of
the data for as well as hct116 and a
suspension cell line that your cat cells
basically we were passing the cells in 6
well plates so essentially larger well
placed to have an upsell to plate for
experiments we have passed a known cell
number every two to three days and then
we would plate these cells in either 96
or 384 well plates for future assays as
a proof of principle the system itself
utilized an integrated site amatsu see
incubator to allow the culture ourselves
directly and bring them on to the system
in an automated fashion it also had an
integrated by cell XR cell viability
analyzer shown on the right and this
would enable us to counter cells at
times pathogen it also had a tilting out
for a larger well placed to basically
allow the media to slide all to one side
and enable us to remove that media
without disturbing the cells and we also
had the integrated spectra max I 3x with
mini max that I mentioned earlier and we
use this for some imaging and cell
counting assays which will describe
later so now we'll show a video again
that will really demonstrate how this
work flow proceeds and how we utilize
the different integrated instruments
so shown here is the automated approach
we took to automating cell culture
starting from the larger 6 well plates
and moving assays into 96-well formats
shown here is the tilting out and the
advantage of this is that the media can
be removed from the edge of the well
without disturbing the adherent cells on
the well we use the span aid system with
ap1000 to reach into the corner well and
remove the media and then another p1000
tip to dispense eight hundred
microliters of trypsin to remove the
cells from the surface of the plate this
plate was then incubated at 37 degrees
for five minutes and this was done on
aesthetic pelletier but could easily
have not been done on the integrated
incubator as well we then use our
optimized pipetting to pipette around
the circumference of the well to make
sure the cells were removed from the
surface of the plate and then also did a
mixing step to ensure that the cells
were distributed into a single cell
suspension a portion of these
resuspended cells were then added to the
sample cup for the integrated by cell
cell viability analyzer and device l
returned a viable cells per mil number
which the biomech was then automatically
able to use to calculate what volume of
cells needed to be transferred to reach
a certain number of cells if the volume
was over one mil the capacity of the tip
the split volume step could be used to
automatically transfer the larger volume
in this case we dispense 1 million cells
into the subsequent well for continuing
passages and a second subset of cells
was then added to a large multi-channel
reservoir containing 100 mils of media
one of the advantages of the large
capacity multi-channel head is that we
are now able to completely mix these
large volume reservoirs and ensure the
cells were evenly distributed throughout
the reservoir in addition we were able
to increase the throughput by using a
multi dispense feature allowing us to
plate for 96-well plates with 200
microliters per well and a single
transfer step
again this can be used to increase
throughput and process numerous plates
simultaneously or processes many plates
in the subsequent fashion as needed
so hopefully that gives you a pretty
good idea of what the automation looks
like in what the workflow looks like
will now look at some of the data that
came off the system so the first
question is just regarding the passage
in from 16 well to another so all the
work will show here was done using the
chinese hamster ovary cells grown in
adherent conditions and so demonstrated
here is basically the results of one of
our six well passages shown below is
basically taking four regions of
interest and taking 12 images for each
region by using the spectrum ax minimax
imaging cytometer 24 hours after plating
and what you can see is that basically
there's no clumps of cells no clusters
so it looked like we had a really
effective trypsinization in mixing and
also it looks very evenly distributed
across the four regions so what you can
see on the left is what i could achieve
manually and on the right is what the
system was able to do in an automated
fashion we got very comparable
percentages of confluence right around
60 percent and very low CVS in both
cases indicating again good dispersion
across the wells looking across multiple
passages now so shown here are basically
the automated and a comparison and
manual of what I was able to achieve and
we look at on the left at cell counts
and looking basically how consistent
those were across passages and also
across automation versus manual and on
the right hand side is plotting
viability and so we were able to achieve
consistently above ninety percent
viability in all our six of our
automated passages more interesting is
that actually if you look we were
actually able to achieve results that
were more consistent than I was able to
achieve manually so again looking at CVS
of 7.9 percent in an automated fashion
when comparing cell counts across six
passages was better than the 13.8
percent TVs I was able to achieve
manually you'll also notice that there
was a slightly less cells on average in
the automated well and that's likely
because when we have the plate in a
tilted fashion I can't actually angle
the pipette the way i can when I'm
performing it manually so there's that
small five to ten probably five percent
of the
well that may not necessarily get rinse
down during the automated passage so
we're likely plating the same number of
cells and culturing the same number of
cells became quite harvest the same
number of cells but again we can do this
more consistently in this consistency
can hopefully lead to more consistent
results with our asses when it comes to
actually plating the video demonstrated
plating in 24 96 well plates but we
actually decided to take it one step
further and try and plate into two
384-well plates doing 100 microliters
multi dispenses much like we
demonstrated in the video and so again
100 microliters for well x 768 wells and
what we were able to see is that we did
again imaging after 24 hours and we then
look to see did we get consistent
distribution of the cells across the
plates so essentially that they are
mixing in the reservoir works they beget
roughly equivalent cells in all regions
of the plate and that's really
the point two percent are lower across
all the columns and all the rows across
both of the place and finally we looked
at how consistent was our multi
dispensed basically we are we getting
the same number of cells for each
dispensed in all of the eight quadrants
and when we compare the average counts
per quadrant we saw CV is less than
seven percent so again a very consistent
passage and plating hopefully resulting
in consistent as a results another
consideration that we've touched on
earlier is multi-day workflows so for
example we've just played at our 96 or a
384-well plate how long do these placing
to incubate is there an additional
treatment how long till we assay them
these things all have to be taken into
consideration because very rarely is
this a single day of approach so when
automating these types of approaches
there's a number of requirements one
main one is that you need to have good
resource management and scheduling and
this comes back to our san ve x software
where again when you're processing
multiple plates it will find the most
efficient way to process those plates in
batchwise fashion i'd also require
sample tracking you need to know where
your samples are at any given time in
the workflow and you also need to know
if your biomech will be available on a
given day so if you have interleaved
multi-day workflows our sami process
management software can help schedule
these things on a calendar so you can
ensure that again will you need to come
in on a weekend is the instrument
already being taken up for other assays
on a given day and finally you need good
data tracking and this is where our data
acquisition and reporting tool dart
comes into account basically these types
of multi-day assays may be made up of
little islands of automation right where
you will bring it in on day zero feed
the cells send them to the incubator
bring them back on day three treat them
dart is basically our tool that every
time that plate comes in it can read the
barcode and know everything that's been
done to that place to date and all of
that information is carried forward so
that eventually your treatment and your
eventual as a result will all be located
in the same database on the same well
so to wrap up the automated cell culture
portion of the work of the talk today I
hopefully have shown you that we were
able to handle larger well plates and
flats really using the span capabilities
but having that combination of pipettors
the span for those 6 well plates in the
multi-channel for the microtiter plates
really is valuable for this type of
workflow there are some caveats one is
that you may need to do some
optimization for any given new cell line
one example is the frequency of passages
so for example when we were passing the
jurkat cells we had passed them every
two days and they were completely happy
the cho cells when we tried to pass it
to them every two days seem to actually
die off a little bit and so that's why
we packed it off to three days another
consideration is the trypsinization
workflows for adherent cells one is just
the trypsinization time five minutes of
incubation work great for the cho cell
lines but the hct116 cells were a little
more aggregated and so you might want to
consider extending that time closer to
seven to eight minutes in addition the
volume that you transfer into the next
well is somewhat dependent on just your
cell size for example if you have a
confluent hct116 well you can fit about
five million cells per well as opposed
to the cho cells where compliments well
only had 2.5 times ten to six so if you
are transferring a million cells into
the next well and you were concerned
about residual trypsin you're actually
transferring twice the amount of volume
in the cho cells as you are on the
hct116 so if you do find the need to
either spin out any of those reagents
obviously there are some automated
solutions for that as well and you can
do media exchanges and not have to worry
about residual trypsin and finally it
comes down to make steps as well as I
mentioned the hct116 cells we're a
little more clumping than the cho cells
were and so we basically increase the
number of mixes that we performed
another consideration is the plating
needs one of the nice features of the
biomech is that you're able to do
data-driven decisions so for example if
your cells haven't grown as much as you
thought they might and you're already in
the middle of passage in them you can
actually just have some if-then
statements indicating that if you don't
have a number high enough number of
cells to do your cell plating you can
just go ahead and passage them and
pushed it off for another couple days
without wasting all the plastic
so that basically wraps up the talk will
kind of try and bring it back to the
simplicity efficiency adaptability and
reliability and see if we've hopefully
shown some examples of how these apply
to cellular applications when it comes
to simplicity having that volume
splitting feature where again it really
doesn't necessarily care what the volume
is you need transfer you don't
necessarily need to put in any sort of
conditional statements or scripting
whatever the results from the buy-sell
come back we can always just basically
have a transfer split the number of
transfers it needs to get the correct
volume also having the integrations be
more direct obviously you can fit a lot
of instruments in a smaller footprint
and not necessarily requiring any
additional robotic transports to access
these devices really increases the
simplicity of those types of integrated
systems when it comes to efficiency and
we have the high-capacity deck there's
just more room more real estate to work
with so you can really have these more
highly complex workflows as you need can
all fit on potentially onto the same
deck and there's also the ability to do
the large volume transfers with the
multi-channel heads as we demonstrated
for the plating video and obviously this
can really just make it a more efficient
workflow you can process more place in a
more rapid fashion when it comes to
adaptability hopefully I've shown that
we were able to automate a pretty
diverse number of workflows on the same
system really kind of indicating that
yes these really can be adapted to
pretty much any need you have and also
the ability to use the multi-channel
selective tip really does increase the
flexibility of that multi-channel head
so again you're able to do more with
that head alone I want to come to
reliability obviously having the remote
monitoring some of these cellular
applications via lies in particular can
take multiple hours so if you want to
just be able to check on your system it
should still be running but again being
able to monitor what's happening
remotely does provide you that extra
sense of security and having our pro
service being able to access any sort of
error logs or those video files really
should be able to help decrease any
downtime that the system might have so
with that I'll wrap up obviously we have
more information available I've just
kind of touched
some of the applications but if you want
more details such as the volumes we were
using or the specific reagents that type
of information can be found in our
application notes as well as a variety
of other resources that can be found at
biomech Beckman calm and with that I'm
happy to take any questions thank you
dr. Costa for that informative
presentation so dis time for Q&A if you
have a question you'd like to ask dr.
Kowalski please do so now just click on
the green to an a button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on your screen and click on the send
button will answer as many questions as
we have time for my first question is
having successfully automated cell
culture without the tilting help like
optimizing captioning that's a great
question and again it might necessarily
depend on a given workflow for example
the large one well places they're called
that would potentially be a little
trickier to kind of work our way around
but the six wall plate we are able to
ask rate around the circumference and
that would be a just as effective way of
removing the media without disturbing
the cells it might just take a little
longer to kind of execute that process
so there's definitely a time in a place
where the tilting up where it provides
value but certainly not required for
most of the place up to the very large
maybe one well place or for example the
auto flasks which really only have a
single point of entry that's where again
the tilting out might be required
otherwise it may just have benefits for
some of the place that probably isn't
necessary how hard is it to adapt the
automation to different workflows that's
also a good question so the the
workflows I've shown today we're all
essentially done using the same deck but
obviously it depends what system you'd
be working on having the i7 hybrid sort
of provides you with the most
flexibility but there are certain
occasions where again depending on your
workloads if things are changing
dramatically you can imagine possibly
needing to change what devices are
integrated to the system one of the nice
things on the iseries is again there's
more universality of the integration so
those do become more easily swapped in
and out but when it comes to just
changing the positions on the deck for
example
needed more heating and cooling
positions or more shaking positions or
had some direct integration that change
to your deck configuration that's very
easily done that's basically just
popping out the current else positions
putting on the next positions and then
doing a quick otto frame using our tools
that are available when it comes to
possibly swapping out heads for example
you can change between the 96 and the
384 multi-channel head that process is
basically just unscrewing four screws
and screwing them back in so even
changing for that type of workflow is
very rapid so does it's basically built
and designed to have high levels of
flexibility so again barring some sort
of massive reconstruction of of your
needs it should be very quickly able to
switch between workflows or otherwise
you may be able to just automate a
number of workflows on a single
configuration how do you handle
contamination yeah so this comes up a
lot actually so in seven years of doing
this I've only run into it once and my
way of dealing with it was to throw out
the contaminated plate I really didn't
have any other problems that's kind of
one of the benefits that in theory if
things are working right you shouldn't
really be spreading contamination so if
you want to treat it the way I would
treat a contaminated incubator you can
spray things down with ethanol but just
throwing away the plate was sufficient
for me I didn't really have any
continuing problems after that there was
not really any need to do anything
extreme but there are certainly you know
we do have information on chemical
compatibility if people really need more
information about sterilization but
honestly for me everything stays pretty
well contained within the place so
throwing it out took care of my problem
after waiting for additional questions
to come in i would like to once again
thank dr. Kowalski for his presentation
do you have any final comments again
just want to thank everyone for
attending today obviously we're
available for additional information and
when it comes to cellular workflows or
obviously my colleagues have presented
on some genomic workflows as well so
this is obviously just one aspect of
what you can do with automation and what
you can do with the biomech guys
so we're happy to always provide more
additional information as required thank
you I would also like to thank our
sponsor beckman coulter life sciences
for making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through october twenty of 2017 you'll
receive an email from laggards letting
you knowing this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues you
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon bye